and finally neural casting directors
have to stop listening to the casting
police and go back to doing their job
which is picking the best actor for the
role
now i mention this because a lot of
people lately are either apologizing for
or calling on others to apologize for
playing roles they call appropriation
james franco was just chosen to play
fidel castro and john leguizamo posted
no more appropriation boycott this is
[ __ ] up
i don't got a problem with franco but he
ain't latino
okay but john leguizamo was
colombian-american he ain't a venetian
but he played one
he ain't a french little person
or an italian plumber but he played them
too because he's
because he's an actor
why the hell do you think people become
actors because they want to spend their
life not being who they are
appropriating sounds like an
unforgivable sin until you remember
that's what acting is
that's why acting jobs are called roles
sean penn won an oscar for playing gay
civil rights martyr harvey milk at the
time it was considered a courageous act
of solidarity for a straight male movie
star to play a homosexual
now it's the opposite
eddie redmayne played a transgender
woman in the danish girl but now calls
that a mistake because many people don't
have a chair at the table
well actually in movies now they do
and what does it have to do with you
playing trans
does it then work the other way can
trans actors only play trans characters
because that's not going to be a good
deal for them
and isn't the best acting always about
making us feel our common humanity
beyond separate identities
a black george washington in hamilton of
course
but
ryan gosling as frederick douglass yes
that would be problematic
ditto shia labeouf has shaft no
it's
why don't we just go by merit and let
the best actor win which seems like what
happened when anna diarmas just got
picked to play marilyn monroe even
though she's cuban with an accent
hey
maybe she should play fidel castro
and james franco can play marilyn monroe
and then we can all
then we can all stay in our lanes
is that what diversity and inclusion
look like now everybody's staying in
their lane
lawrence of arabia was gay peter o'toole
wasn't i can live with that because he
was so cool he almost made me gay
emma stone caught help for playing a
hawaiian jake gyllenhaal for playing a
persian gal gadot for wanting to play
cleopatra johnny depp for playing an
indian
even though he's not an actual comanche
and spoiler alert he also doesn't really
have scissor hands
[Applause]
and he's not actually a drunken pirate
okay bad example
tom hanks
now says that if philadelphia were made
today he wouldn't do it because the
character was gay and he's not
well besides the fact that this would
force all gay actors to reveal their
sexuality even if they didn't want to
great actors which tom has won
try hard to keep their private lives
private so we don't think of their real
lives when we see them in a movie that
attempts to transport us into a
different world could you really look at
this actress now
and not think of the trial
should she only play bed [ __ ] now
[Applause]
what's daniel day lewis really like i
haven't a clue which is why he's so
great because when he plays lincoln i
only see lincoln i don't think well
there's a british heterosexual
[Laughter]
but hanks says i don't think people
would accept the inauthenticity of a
straight guy playing a gay guy because
quote we're beyond that now don't get
them started on bosom buddies
i mean
really
does forrest gump get thrown under the
bus too because tom isn't really
mentally challenged
and as far as we're beyond that no
no that implies progress this is the
opposite this is regression
and it's
and it is
frankly typical of so much wokeness that
doesn't build on liberalism it undoes it
empathy putting yourself in someone
else's place so you can understand them
better used to be the very heart of
liberalism now it's considered offensive
because don't even try to put yourself
in my shoes because you could never know
what a bunch of [ __ ] that always was
of course no one can ever know exactly
what another person's struggle is but we
try
black like me was a 1950s book about a
white man who darkened his skin and went
out into society because he wanted to
understand
what his black brothers and sisters were
up against today
all the woke mob would see
about that was a guy who did blackface
steven spielberg recently remade west
side story and bent over backwards to
respect ethnicities and ended up
pleasing nobody and it's too bad because
the original musical was created by
stephen sondheim arthur lorenz and
leonard bernstein three gay jews
and if you can't trust gay jews to write
about hot-blooded puerto rican teenagers
who can you trust
next thing you're going to tell me
street gangs don't even dance
and now they're making a movie about
leonard bernstein and bradley cooper is
playing it i mean if he can get through
the picket lines you see like rachel
brosnahan playing mrs maisel and helen
mirren playing israeli prime minister
gold in my ear bradley is sadly a
gentile and
that's the new sin in hollywood being a
non-jewish actor portraying a jew
because that's always been the problem
in hollywood not enough jews
woke even have a word for this troubling
new phenomenon jew face
do you see what i mean about them having
their head up their ass really the word
you're using to fight anti-semitism is
ju-face
it sounds like something mel gibson says
at a traffic stop
you